I don't go over here and I've moved down
a bit okay so wait till not me it would
really help us if you didn't hurt anyone
during this okay people in the front row
maybe just protect your money making
music yeah I mean you need music to do
now
okay so we become a like a come on
Michael Michael Michael come on we've
got to shoot Michael listen
bum bum ba-bum ba-bum console
very good
oh yeah
so when I hear when I hear it all the
time I just started picking it up and
started like I could pick up their
accent and do their accent a little bit
anomaly I'm okay it's gonna sound really
embarrassing to do in front of a whole
room full of Brits here but I'll try it
anyways so it's like so I want to say I
like a silly scar
they did like Michael cheat on me was in
a beeper
you know jeez Paul painted with fries
okay
quarter pounder quarter pound of it how
much is it it's about 750 Jeremy
oh I see from her
Missoula vader kenobi palpatine
calrissian balboa rambo griswold
stepford bickle gump corleone wonka
Sivaji lebowski venkman spengler stands
rizzo zuko like the higgins dolittle
poppins bond blow-for-blow tarski like
your soze o'hara do Frankel so McFly the
bag explicitly territorial burgundy says
he has driven striker Buell Electra
Potter Weasley Dumbledore sparrow
doubtfire bourne white Ramsey later Kurt
smart boy [ __ ] con all right ready
okay we own the Graham Norton Show and I
have some as the LaVista boys there is
no bathroom I'm old not obsolete
don't make no sense at all every morning
tell me how you're feeling it would go
fantastic terrific great oh yeah strong
juice baby sucker I feel wonderful right
on right on right on juice juice juice
let's kick some ass kicks up number one
we are who's number two
what do me to sing oh sing bang bang yes
I'm a painting
no one told you life is gonna be this
way